all right game started against the
player from french guiana Wow
international master interesting
interesting flex you learn here on the
RCC let's see we've got some kind of red
team ready opening okay up I use the
chance to to get some some space here 98
is designed to prepare at sex f 695 to
support the porn here yeah this is some
this is also take a theoretical line I
think he even can go to be five maybe
not quite sure this is the position but
it's sometimes possible this kind of
setups it that looks very strange here
yeah maybe this is most likely some some
different position ok let's go me 50 /
the Sun this is looking strange what
about Bishop g4 does he intend to play a
3 then oh ok can give this this
intermediate check ok first get this
night to a better position and contour
don't want to spend so much time here
maybe Bishop g4 would have been
interesting if you play if I play this
now Bishop g4 he would play neither
three maybe but the stutter looks like a
decent move maybe you can take b7 and
try to sack the exchange here from the
light squares would be an idea that I
that I would consider maybe now they
didn't didn't play this okay we should
be seven now maybe protecting the bishop
preventing h3 and yeah this looks decent
all right maybe maybe he's some tending
to play before I could prevent this
button when I day six write a six and
maybe m95 later if it takes 95 I think I
should should get this back somehow
uh-huh interesting but take a I ok
divorce may be hanging because of his
seven still it look strange to to give
this I think I take this chance this
King should be weak let's say night or
Bishop c5 whatever Bishop c5 if he moves
the night which I think he needs to do
g3 is just hanging because of this pin
what's happening after the smooth
get the win apiece I well okay we can he
can yeah okay here he gave him away the
piece it gets a couple of points though
ok do it take with the pawn I did take
with the bishop the tape with the pawn
you might go be fine i don't have a
decent square ok let's take with the
bishop of course he can prob where he
can play this and capture my material
but I hope look the aid and maybe night
the quick night c5 would put mean and
not enough enough activity for me he's
got six he's got two pawns and the night
a son is really a bad piece at the
moment
yeah should I play f5 f5 the idea of f4
i guess i need to to use his son this
wicked King somehow okay he just ignores
this all okay i forced not a deadly
threat or something roop t6 now he's got
ruki eight at some point maybe
so I need to try to play against the
skin yet this night is just bad it's my
extra night but it's doing nothing I
don't see how I'm how to quickly
activate it yeah okay but now I have
four right to really get some activity
guy threatening f3 and taking on g3 he
cannot plan Quinn to g2 because of
taking at f3 + f3 is a threat strong one
cannot take out so it causes a check on
g6 yeah now can take on g 3m Queen g3
Ruby six wins the Queen all right check
time worry yeah this should be too much
now I get the night into play white
resides yeah somewhat somewhat strange
game and very very strange idea to play
h3 here and I'll just is just lost
material but it wasn't trying to clear
from a practical point of view because
my night is so so often on a6 center it
doesn't have a very clear route maybe
maybe maybe you've not be eight year
maybe not be eight would have been an
idea to go 96 moon night be hm this is
maybe also was correct yeah I didn't see
this in the game yeah an ID be ages
strong or slightly
yeah the conv also gives me you not be 8
computer also gives night p 8 yeah yeah
it's the best it's just just good to get
this extra piece and to play it it's
doing nothing on a six and it needs to
get into play as soon as possible I was
all only thinking about night to c7 on
or c5 to e6 to g5 his kind of roots but
98 somehow escaped me I did seem pretty
quickly here it's an analysis but not in
the game yeah interesting ok the next
game